欢迎大家参加
Welcome everybody, to the
FP101x 函数式程序设计
FP101x functional programming MOOC.
I'm really happy that we can do this one
这门包含练习之类的慕课
as a MOOC with exercises and
everything.
让我们现在就开始吧
Let's get started
在讨论其他事情之前 我想说的是
immediately. One thing that I wanted
to tell you before we get going
正如标题所说 这门慕课是关于函数式程序设计的
is that this is a MOOC about functional
programming that's what the title says
它不是一门 Haskell 课程 我们是将
FP101 functional programming. This is
not a course on Haskell, were using
Haskell
作为一门函数式语言 但我们不是学习如何用 Haskell 编程的
as a functional language but we're not
learning to program Haskell per se.
让我给你讲一个小故事吧
Let me tell you a little bit
of a story.
我经常旅行 开会
I travel a lot, going to conferences,
讲课 等等
giving courses et cetera
旅行途中 我有很多时间来看电视
and during those travels I have ample
time to watch TV.
有一天晚上 当我随意调台时
One night I was zapping through the channels
看到一档求生类节目
and there was one of those survival
shows
里面一个人试着在晚上扎营
where this guy was trying to make up
并且想要点火
camp at night and trying to make a fire
但是火柴都湿了
but his matches were wet.
也许他会很慌乱并说
He could have gotten in panic and said:
我的火柴湿了 点不着火了
my matches are wet I cannot make a fire.
但他做的却是拿出一部手机
What he did instead is he took a
cell phone
用他的刀
and his knife and he
把电池从上面拆了下来 并打开了电池
took the battery out of his cell phone,
opened the battery
之后电池开始燃烧
and then the battery started to combust.
他就用这个点着了火
That's what he used to start a fire.
And this is the same
这也是我想在这门课中教给你的态度
attitude that I want to teach you in
this course.
当我们用 Haskell 学习函数式程序设计时
While we're learning to do
functional programming using Haskell so
Haskell 是我们的火柴
Haskell's our matches,
在实际工作中 你可能没有火柴能用
when at work you don't have matches
available
但你仍然可以进行函数式编程 有时你需要拆开你的
you still can do functional programming.
Sometimes you have to smash your
手机
cell phone
打开你的电池才能生火 别认为这只是关于
and open your battery to start a fire.
Don't think that this is about
Haskell 的 我们用是 Haskell 但教的是函数式程序设计
Haskell per se, we're going to teach
functional programming
好了 现在让我们
using Haskell.
Alright, let's get
开始吧
started then.
我们要解决的是什么问题？
What's the problem that we're trying to
solve? The problem
要解决的问题就是所谓的 软件危机
is the so called software crisis.
We all know
我们都知道开发者写代码十分困难
as developers that writing code is
pretty difficult.
我们需要写大型的程序
We're writing huge programs and
同时又要缩减开发时间 降低开发成本
what we need to do is to reduce the
time
我们希望快速发布软件
and the cost of development.
We want to deliver software fast
又希望发布的软件正确无误
and we want to deliver correct software.
The question is
问题是我们如何写程序
how can we make programs
来保证我们有信心认为软件正确工作呢？
such that that we are confident that our
programs work
我们又如何写代码
and how can we make code
来实现快速发布
such that this code is delivered fast.
不是几年后才发布
It doesn't take years to deliver but
it takes
而是几个月或者更短 一种现代编程语言中
months or as long as it needs to be.
One way to do that, and we see this now
常见的实现方式是 为编程语言增加特性
in all modern programming languages, is to
add features to our languages
允许程序的表达方式简洁清晰
that allow programs to be written
clearly concisely and at a high level of
抽象层次也较高
abstraction.
我们在现代编程语言中使用的这些技术
And the techniques that we use in these
modern languages
都是基于函数式程序设计
are all based on functional programming.
These techniques
基于 lambda 演算的概念
are all based on concepts from the
lambda calculus.
Haskell 是一种
And Haskell is a
纯函数式编程语言
functional language that is pure and
therefore
因此适用于这些概念的教学
a really good vehicle to teach these
concept.
函数式编程语言
Functional languages
则提供一种十分优雅的框架
therefore provide a very elegant framework
让我们在一个较高的抽象层次写代码
to write code at a high level of
abstraction.
但正如我说过的 Haskell 只是一个工具
But as I said, Haskell is just our
vehicle.
我们在这门课中所学到的东西
What we learn in this course, you
will be able to apply this
你可以用于任何编程语言 即使你用的是汇编语言
to any language even if you're programming
in assembly
Java 或 PHP
or in Java or in PHP
或者 JavaScript 你在这里学习到的想法
or in JavaScript, all the ideas that you
will learn here
可以立刻用在
you can apply immediately
无论你用的哪种编程语言中
in whatever language you're happening
to use.
那么什么是函数式编程语言呢？
What is a functional programming
language?
可能的回答有很多
The ideas about that
现在还没有明确的定义
vary, there's no real clear
definition.
如果我们考虑最纯的函数式编程语言
If we take a very purist approach a
functional language
那么函数式编程语言就是使用数学函数编程的语言
is a language in which we program using
mathematical functions.
这一定义适用于 Haskell 它本身是一门
And that definition applies to Haskell,
which is a pure language, one of the very
纯函数式语言
few
在函数式语言中仅有很少几门是纯的
functional programming languages that is
pure. But of course
当然 我在说我们可以将这些技术应用到其他编程语言中
and when I say that we can use these
techniques to program also in other
的时候
languages
我们不能使用这个定义
we cannot use that definition.
我们要用的时下面的定义
What will use in this course is the
following definition:
函数式编程语言
functional programming
是一种编程的风格
is a style of programming in which
其中表达式比语句更为重要
expressions are more important than
using statements.
我们想做的事情时用表达式组成程序
What we want to do is: we want to
compose programs using expressions
这些表达式都可以求值 因此我们可以把两个可以求值的
and these expressions deliver a value so
we take two expressions that deliver a
表达式
value
组合起来成为一个更大的表达式
and compose them in a bigger expression.
比较一下使用语句编程
Compare and contrast that with writing
your program using statements.
当你将语句组合起来的时候 每条语句都有隐藏的副作用
When you compose statements the
statements have an implicit side-effect
这些副作用影响全局状态 它们通过全局状态实现通信
on the global state and they
communicate values via that global
state.
而使用表达式编程时
Whereas in an expression based
表达式返回一个值
programming style expressions return
values
我们直接将值组合起来 一门函数式编程语言
and we compose these values directly.
A functional programming language
就是支持并且鼓励
is a language that supports and
encourages
使用表达式编程的语言
writing code using expressions.
正如我说过的一样 大部分现代语言
As I said before, most modern
languages
现在都支持这种风格
now support this style.
And they support the style
特别时通过支持 lambda 表达式来实现这一点
specifically by supporting lambda
expressions.
随着课程的进行 我们可以在很多很多语言中
We'll see examples of functional
programming
看到函数式编程的例子
in many many languages as we progress
让我们
through this course. Let's
从第一段代码开始吧
start with our first fragment of code
here.
这是一种老式的 Java 编程风格
This is some old-fashioned Java
我们要计算 1 到 10 的加和
where we're computing the sum of the
integers from one to ten.
我们做的方式 使用传统的过程式编程风格
The way we do that, as I said, in the
traditional imperative
它是基于语句的
style, this is based by doing
我们做的第一件事是声明了一个整数类型的
statements. The first thing we do
is we declare a variable total
变量 total 并将它初始化为 0
of type int. We initialize it with zero
接下来我们用一个循环变量写一个 for 循环
and then we write a for loop with a
loop variable.
你可以看到这边的变量 i
That int i, that you see there and then we
然后我们给 total 变量赋值
assign to that the total
variable:
成为 total + i 你可以看到
total variable + i. Here you see that
这个程序是用一种
the program is written
过程式的风格写的 我们有语句
in an imperative style.
We have statements,
我们有可变状态
we have mutable state and we
我们过程式地执行一条语句接一条语句
imperatively execute statement after
statement
更新状态来计算最终结果
updating the state to compute the result.
这是你用 Haskell 编写相同程序的方式
Now here is how you would write that same
program
你可以看到的第一点是
in Haskell. The first thing you see is
that it's
程序更加简洁 另一点是没有语句了
much more concise but the other thing is
that there's no statement. It's just
只有两个表达式
two expressions.
The expression you see
这里
here
右面这个 1 点点 10 （1..10）
on the right. One dot dot ten.
创建了一个从 1 到 10 的整数列表
Creates a list of the integers from one
to ten.
然后我们仅仅将这些整数相加
And then we just sum those integers up.
所以你可以看到我们使用表达式
So here you see that we're composing
来组合成为程序 一个表达式创建从 1 到 10 的列表
the code by having an expression.
One that creates this list from one to ten
我们将它的返回值应用到
and then we apply that value
sum 函数上 从而把内容求和
to a function sum that will sum things
在 Java 8 中
up for us. In Java 8
你可以用 Java 8 的流（streams）
you can write the same code
写同样的程序
using Java 8 streams, we will
我们将在未来的课程中深入探讨 Java 8
dive deeper into Java 8 and a future
但现在我们只看用 Haskell 实现的方式
lesson but for now here is the way
十分感谢
we do this in Haskell.
Thank you
第二部分再见
and see you in part two.